To build applications that
use Google Play services,
you need a development environment.
And to install the development
environment there's two
main things that you'd need.
First, is Android studio.
You can download Android studio
from the developer.google.com site.
When you install Android studio,
you get the ability to use the Android
SDK Manager, that you can see here.
And using the Android SDK Manager,
you should install
the Google Play Services SDK.
You'll see it as an item on the list,
under extras,
near the bottom of the screen.
Make sure that you install
the most recent version of this.
I would also recommend that you take a
look at the Android Fundamentals courses
offered by Udacity.
There are two of them at the moment, and
I strongly recommend that
you at least take the first.
And it's really not a bad idea
to take the second as well.
These will give you a head start
in Android development and
teach you many of the concepts that
we'll be covering in this course.